hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well near the end of
the introduction to work the second sex
Simone de Beauvoir is going to lay her
cards on the table so to speak and set
out some of the outlines of her
existentialist approach to this question
of the relation between men and women
and this is going to be quite critical
of other approaches which frame things
in terms you might say of a zero-sum
solution so she talks about people who
have have screwed up the the you know
the women question right she says it's
because it's been turned into a quarrel
and when we quarrel we no longer reason
well people have tirelessly sought to
prove that woman is superior inferior
equal to man she gives some examples of
arguments made on this basis one prime
example is that of the relation to an
Adam and Eve right you could say well
Adam is first and whatever comes first
must be the best Eve is merely
derivative of Adam so therefore she's
inferior or you might say on the
opposite side listen when you make a
first try at something it's usually not
as good
so obviously Adam was just God's first
attempt and Eve is the much better newer
model that you know took into account
the flow
cause of the first one and and she goes
on and she says listen these arguments
at once suggests they're opposites and
both are often fallacious this is not
getting us anywhere and why is it that
the only options before us would be
women are superior to men women are
inferior to men or women are equal to
men is that really the entire gamut of
possibilities she doesn't think so
and so she says that what we need to do
is discard these vague notions of
superiority inferiority and equality
because they've corrupted every
discussion of the subject and we should
begin afresh so how would we do this she
points out that men have been both the
the judge he says and party to the case
of the relationship between men and
women but then again so have women so
it's not like men or women can genuinely
be impartial in this matter so what if
we found some third position something
perhaps different you know an angel she
says we would need some sort of angel
who is neither man nor woman perhaps not
even bodily and she says well to begin
with where are you gonna find that but
even if you did how the hell would that
help you such a creature wouldn't have
enough knowledge about the conditions
that we actually live in to adjudicate
the case what if instead you found some
sort of in-between she talks about the
hermaphrodite as a possibility you know
her mates Aphrodite male/female together
and she says with the hermaphrodite we'd
be no better off because the situation
is peculiar the hermaphrodite is not
really the combination of an entire man
and an entire woman but rather parts of
each and thus is neither when she says
it looks to me as if there are certain
women who are best qualified to
elucidate the situation of women but
that doesn't help us all that much so
what do we have to do we have to lay our
cards on the table she says it's
doubtless impossible to approach
any human problem with a mind free of
bias the way in which questions are put
the points of view assumed presupposed a
relativity of interest all
characteristics imply values every
objective description implies an ethical
background so instead of pretending that
we have a view from nowhere about the
relationship between men and women and
we have this purely objective standpoint
she suggests taking the standpoint of
existentialist ethics like that which
she developed in her work the ethics of
ambiguity and in other places as well
now one thing to point out about this
we're going to get to a little bit later
is that this is going to prioritize
freedom over happiness as a fundamental
criterion and it's also going to be
oriented towards the individual and not
just the individual as part of a group
so she goes on and she says what we
should do is state our principles at the
beginning so this will make it
unnecessary to specify in just what
sense one uses words like superior
inferior better worse progress reaction
if we do that from the start then maybe
these words come to assume a different
richer meaning so de Beauvoir is an
existentialist what does that mean for
us
she says well when it comes to the
interest of people she says that if we
serve survey works on women we note that
one of the points of view most
frequently adopted is that of the public
good the general interest and one almost
always means by this the benefit of
society as one wishes it to be
maintained or established she's not
saying that that's no good what she's
saying that's not her point of view
instead what is her point of view she
says we hold that the only public good
is that which assures the private good
of the citizens we should pass judgment
on institutions according to their
effectiveness in giving concrete
opportunities to individuals so if you
want to say that for example public
education
something that we ought to be supporting
and we ought to do whatever we can to
make it better to resist those who want
to get rid of it or simply privatize it
you don't look just at what the
aggregate result is you have to look at
how it actually affects individual human
beings what does it afford to them what
possibilities does it open up for them
and she goes on and she says I'm not
going to confuse the idea of private
interest with that of happiness because
that's another common point of view
instead it's going to be the point of
view of freedom so another key aspect to
this is what she calls transcendence and
this is coming out of existentialism as
well human beings are kind of weird mix
between imminence which is the reality
as we have it right here which for her
she views as connected with stagnation
if we if we treat ourselves just as we
are just in our being just as objects
then we're trying to hold ourselves to
be sort of like this piece of chalk just
what it is
nothing more no potentialities beyond
what's already in there and when we do
that sort of thing we're denying our
status as human beings which are the the
particular kinds of beings that can
transcend their situations and this is
what our freedom consists in so she goes
on and she says here we go every subject
plays his part is such specifically
through exploits or projects that serve
as a mode of transcendence in creating
this video for example in trying to
explicate Simone de Beauvoir thoughts I
am transcending I am going beyond in in
trying to understand her on your end but
perhaps by means of this video perhaps
by means of getting rid of it
and just reading the book directly
you're doing something similar as well
she goes on and says a human being
achieves liberty only through a
continual reaching out toward
other liberties it's never a finished
thing our being our essence is always
something in determination so she says
there is no justification for present
existence other than its expansion into
an indefinitely open future every time
there's another key point transcendence
falls back into imminence stagnation
there is a degradation of existence into
the Aqua
that's a particular term that's used by
Sartre to mean in itself being in itself
something that just is what it is and
she says the brutish life is subjection
to given conditions and of liberty and
constraint and contingents so she says
this downfall represents a moral fall if
the subject consents to it if this is
imposed upon them and you consent to it
that is a problem she says if it's
inflicted upon the person it spells
frustration and oppression and then she
says in both cases it's an absolute evil
every individual concern to justify
their existence feels their existence
involves an undefined need to transcend
oneself to engage in freely chosen
projects so that's the existentialist
ethics they're in you know sort of a
nutshell how does that apply to women
she talks about the drama women and it
consists she says in this conflict
between the fundamental aspirations of
every subject who always regards the
self as the essential and the compulsion
of a situation in which she is the in
essential she says the situation of
woman is that on the one hand she's a
free and autonomous being like all human
creatures but she finds herself living
in a world in which she is in which men
compel her to assume the status of the
other she says they propose to stabilize
her as an object and to doom her to
imminence sense her transcendence is to
be overshadowed and forever transcended
by another ego another self which is the
male
so on the one hand a woman is treated as
if she is a full human being capable of
transcendence on the other hand that
transcendence is being harnessed you
might say so that it can serve another
transcendence and she's being treated as
an object this doesn't just have to do
with what we call sexual objectification
it happens anytime that a mother is
reduced just to a piggy bank and the
person who cleans and cooks or that any
any time that you know a woman is
offered the chance to engage in the
female gaze and be the one objectifying
the peacock male we could go on and on
and on about examples of this sort of
thing but de pouvoir sees this as the
essential problem and resolving this is
going to require us to get beyond these
obsessions with whether men and women as
classes are superior inferior or equal
to each other and to think about
concrete cases and relationships in
which we can still use these terms of
superior inferior and equal but in which
they're going to assume a richer and
deeper meaning
you